hey guys Pete here this is my watchman
Episode five trailer breakdown Episode
five will air on HBO this Sunday with
the title little fear of lightning the
title is part of a quote from 20,000
Leagues Under the Sea by Jules Verne the
full quote is if there were no thunder
men would have little fear of lightning
the episode description reads the origin
story of Looking Glass is revealed as is
the truth behind the greatest hoax in
American history the smartest man in the
world plots a daring escape well toss on
all these things and more as we go
through this trailer scene-by-scene
Episode five will mark the halfway point
of season 1 of HBO's Watchmen and this
video will contain spoilers for
everything that's happened so far and
things that have popped up in different
trailers that were out before the season
started after the breakdown I'll talk
about some theories and clues about
future episodes and I'll give you a
second spoiler warning if you want to
avoid those the episode 5 trailer opens
with the young man who based on the
description is probably Wade Tillman aka
Looking Glass he's walking through a
Hall of Mirrors with his girlfriend and
we've seen this couple in several
preseason teasers and promo at a
carnival in this shot I would say his
girlfriend's clothes look like they
could be from the 1980s and that led to
the idea that this could be on the night
of the squid attack in New York City at
the end of the original comic that
theory feels a whole lot more likely
based on everything else we see in this
trailer in the next scene Laurie
jokingly calls LG mere guy as she calls
out to him he looks like he's having a
conversation with Angela at a desk in
the police station and the next scene
he's opening a garage door wearing his
mask nothing really stands out it just
looks like he's getting ready to drive
somewhere in the voiceover we hear him
say to Laurie I know you know it's
looking glass and we watched as he
enters a room where Laurie's sitting at
a desk and she's reading a file on the
cover there's a photo of a police
officer in uniform it's not clear enough
to make out for sure but it looks like
she's reading LG's file here after that
Laurie addresses the police force saying
we can't see who they are but we can see
where they are you find this church
maybe we find the cavalry there are
shots of the cavalry members and the
detectives listening to her she wants to
find the church at the 7th cavalry film
the video in that they sent to the
police in episode 1 after the shooting
from the traffic stop that cuts to wade
sitting in a circle with other regular
people on a support group meeting no one
looks familiar and based on a sign in
the background it looks like it's taking
place in a church like a 12-step meeting
or something along those lines Wade says
hands which prompts the others to stand
in a circle and join hands together they
say we know there are other dimensions
than this one but this is the dimension
where we live and we will not live in
fear
during that we see pamphlets on a table
next to a box of donuts they read extra
dimensional anxiety and you what's a
photo of a cat looking at their own
reflection in a window to me this is
nearly confirmation that LG is that guy
at the carnival and that he survived the
squid attack that Adrian Veidt
orchestrated to avert the impending
nuclear war back in 1985 in previous
trailers we've seen him come out of the
funhouse naked and it all adds up to be
Wade's life defining event well the
support group is saying their words we
see what could be one of Lady trues
clinics there are a couple of unknown
people here that have Great Danes that
look a lot alike there's a shot of LG
wearing his mask at home he has a spoon
in his hand which makes me think of the
scene from the comic-con trailer where
he's eating beans out of the can with
his mass rolled up watching American
hero story Minute Men last week we saw
him in a backyard bunker so it looks
like he works down there but actually
lives inside the house after that we see
him without the mask looking at a pickup
truck that was used in the shooting in
Episode one the license plate is the
same and we even see some lettuce fall
out of the back to make things extra
clear there's a driver and a passenger
here which makes me think it's not a
flashback to the night of the shooting
but it also seems weird that they would
be driving this truck around after that
of course the shooter could have dropped
the passenger off a little later we see
both of these guys get out of the truck
wearing their Rorschach masks so we'll
have to wait and see what's going on
here and when it's going on from there
we visit Adrian Veidt who's getting help
putting on a much-improved looking
version of the suit he first tested on
one of the
clones a couple episodes back and this
lines up with the smartest men in the
world plotting a daring escape we get
some close-ups of the improvements to
the suit and have to assume it's already
passed some tests if Adrian's putting it
on himself after Miz Crookshanks
attaches the hoses it cuts to a shot of
the catapult being launched by a mr.
Phillips I'll come back to this after
the scene-by-scene because I have some
thoughts and they're based on clips from
different trailers next we have Wade
running into his bunker after closing
the door behind him in the very next
scene he tears this mysterious red box
off a wall and throws it on the ground
this looks like it's in a closet since
there's clothes hanging there and later
when we see him stomping on it it looks
like it's inside his house rather than
the bunker I can't really tell what this
thing is based on these shots it's not
clear there's something on the top of it
that could be a speaker or a microphone
and it was connected to wires that
sparked when he rips it out of the wall
based on everything else in this trailer
I'm guessing this has something to do
with his obsession with the
interdimensional but leave a comment if
you have a good idea of what this box is
because I can't come up with anything
the final part of the voice-over is LG
saying we're all in a tunnel and every
tunnel ends it ends with light that to
me sounds like working your way through
something getting out on the other side
while he's saying that we get a shot of
him looking through binoculars without
his mask probably watching the truck
with the 7k members there's a shot of
him sitting in a desk in his mask
followed by Angela turning to him with
this shocked look on her face the
follow-up shot is of him stopping the
mysterious red box in the bedroom and
then there are two shots that almost
certainly take place in the church that
Lauri wants them to find where the 7th
cavalry shot the video in the first we
see him look around a corner and see a
blue glow light up the shot and in the
second he's looking up surprised but
there's no hints at what he's actually
looking at I'll come back to the blue
glow later because there are more shots
that look like they come from this
episode in the other trailers this
trailer ends with the shot we've seen
before a bright light shining with a
crowd of people looking down at
something on the ground with what we
know now I would guess that these are
mr. Phillips's
Ms Crookshanks looking down at Adrienne
after he makes his attempt on the
catapult but it could just as easily be
on the outside of his enclosure if he's
managed to make it out it's blurry on
purpose so we won't know until we know
and that brings us to the end of the
scene by scene now I'm gonna go into
some speculation theories and things
from other trailers that are probably
from episodes after this one so if
you're not into that type of thing now
is the time to click away please like
the video and subscribe so you can come
back for future watchmen videos it's a
lookingglass episode and i feel fairly
confident that he was at the carnival
when the squid attack happened we see
the bodies are lying everywhere when he
comes out of the funhouse which suggests
that he was one of the few survivors
I've heard I've heard speculation that
he could have been in the Hall of
Mirrors and that somehow protected him
which would later have influenced his
choice of masks the episode 5
description says that the truth of the
greatest hoax in American history is
revealed in the Watchmen universe that
would be the squid attack if LG was
there he's not the only one out of the
characters hanging around the Tulsa
Police Department in the present day
Laurie was also there and she saw the
destruction firsthand with dr. Manhattan
and then she went with him to Karnak in
Antarctica where awesome Andy has
revealed how this was all part of his
plan to end hostilities between the u.s.
and the Soviet Union she even tried to
shoot him but he caught the bullet in
that put in into that we're not sure to
what extent the event in New York has
affected LG's life but we do know that
he's going to a support group he's
rushing out to take photos of the squid
showers as they happen Laurie knows it's
a hoax it didn't actually involve any
real extra-dimensional activity it'll be
interesting to see if she tells him the
truth and how that will end up fitting
into the story everything points to him
being inside the church where the 7k
made the video it looks like he follows
them there but we don't really know how
that all plays out there are more scenes
of him walking around inside the complex
though in the featurette and the
official season 1 trailer that showed
that he is definitely in that same
building we see the wall they used for a
backdrop with the crucifix and we see
the cameras in a different shot he gets
grabbed up by members wearing
Rorschach's in this one and then there's
another scene where someone wearing them
says it's the only way to show you the
truth people have speculated that this
is a woman and that definitely seems
possible it's not clear if this happens
at the same time when he first goes into
the church or who is actually behind the
mask it could be someone from a support
group since it doesn't resemble any of
the characters we know what's curious
about that is he seems like the kind of
guy that could buy into conspiracies so
there may be something to this person
trying to use him to aid the seventh
Cavalry in relation to the police that
blue glow I mentioned earlier is the
most exciting thing about the church
there's another scene from the
featurette where we see an orb drop
through the ceiling and I mean it like
falls through the ceiling and it has
that same light blue light always brings
dr. Manhattan to mind but I cannot come
up with a great theory about what's
going on what it looks like is
something's travelling into our world
through the ceiling in that church but
where it's coming from and anything else
beyond that is pretty much a mystery but
it does look like LG will be the one to
experience something that may at least
feel like it's an interdimensional kind
of situation to him at the time this
week's Ozymandias installment looks
pretty exciting and that he's putting on
that new costume himself and plotting
his daring escape but we have a lot of
scenes from other trailers that look
like they happen after this where he's
still imprisoned as far as we can tell
he's in a Cell when he blows out six or
seven candles on an anniversary cake
this one should probably have five if it
keeps going with the same pattern we've
seen and there's also the trial where
he's wearing his costume and that
definitely doesn't look like it's
happening in the real world there's
Crookshanks is there and like I said
he's wearing the Aussie costume in the
courtroom where we see pigs run across
the floor it's not a stretch to say that
his episode 5 escape plan will be
unsuccessful and that he ends up losing
some of the freedom he has in this
current arrangement as a result we see a
little bit of Angela interacting at the
station but there's no real hints of
lady true and will in this trailer at
all episode 6 is titled this
extraordinary being though and this
description reads deep under the
influence of nostalgia Angela gets a
first-hand account of her grandfather's
journey that sure sounds like we'll get
some answers about what's going on with
why he's doing what he's doing and his
story and the president is connected
with lady T it makes sense that those
stories will be out of the spotlight if
we're doing flashbacks to New York the
support-group angle and of course
finding the 7 K Church in episode 5 in
series this week I haven't seen anything
that I really love people think that
perhaps Cal is dr. Manhattan that one's
out there also that Ozymandias is
physically stuck inside the statue we
saw it lady throughs place because of
the timeline it's possible that he
escapes his imprisonment all before we
ever get to what we see now and then is
encased in that but I don't know I'd
have to get more to make me actually
like that theory there's also a lot of
talk of lady true being Laurie's
half-sister in comedian fathering a
child with a Vietnamese during the war
there's that scene where he murders the
woman and people are connecting those
dots again I'm not really finding it
that compelling but it's out there and
beyond that it seems like we've talked
enough so I'm going to end this video
here let me know in the comments what
you're thinking what you think's going
on what we should expect in episode 5
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon